welcome to another - chair - Mike
episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast today we bring you the
perspectives of two guests on the topic
of reinforcement learning for online
applications since most research wants
to be a product when it grows up we've
brought in a brilliant researcher
program manager duo to illuminate the
classic research incubate transfer
process in the context of real-world
reinforcement learning you're listening
to the Microsoft Research podcast a show
that brings you closer to the cutting
edge of technology research and the
scientists behind it I'm your host
Gretchen using dr. John Langford a
partner researcher in the machine
learning group of Microsoft Research in
New York City is a reinforcement
learning expert who is working in his
own words to solve machine learning
Rapha hosen also of MSR New York is a
principal program manager who's working
to take that work to the world if that
sounds like big thinking in the Big
Apple well New York City has always been
a go big or go home kind of town an MSR
NYC is a go big or go home kind of lab
today dr. Langford explains why online
reinforcement learning is critical to
solving machine learning and how moving
from the current foundation of a Markov
decision process toward a contextual
bandit future might be part of the
solution Rafa hosen talks about why it's
important from a business perspective to
move RL agents out of simulated
environments and into the open world and
gives us an under the hood look at the
product side of MSRs research incubate
transfer process focusing on real-world
reinforcement learning which at
Microsoft is now called Azure cognitive
services personalized er that and much
more on this episode of the Microsoft
Research podcast
[Music]
I've got two guests in the booth today
both working on some big research
problems in the Big Apple
John Langford is a partner researcher in
the machine learning group at MSR NYC
and Rafa hosen also at the New York lab
is the principal program manager for
personalization service also known as
real-world reinforcement learning John
and Rafa welcome to the podcast
thank you Microsoft researches New York
lab is relatively small in the
constellation of MSR labs but there's
some really important work going on
there so to get us started
tell us what each of you does for a
living and how you work together what
gets you up in the morning okay I'll
start so I wake up every day and think
about all the great things that the
reinforcement learning researchers are
doing and first I map what they're
working on something that could be
useful to customers and then I think to
myself how can we take this great
research which typically comes in the
form of a paper to a prototype to an
incubation to something that Microsoft
can make money out of that's a big
thread starting with a little seed and
ending up with you think big that's
right how about you John I want to solve
machine learning and that's ambitious
but one of the things that you really
need to do if you want to solve machine
learning is you need to solve
reinforcement learning which is kind of
a common basis for learning albums to
learn from the interaction with the real
world and so figuring out new ways to do
this or trying to expand the scope of
where we can actually apply these
techniques is what really drives me can
you go a little deeper into solve
machine learning
what would solving machine learning look
like looked like anything that you can
pose as a machine learning problem you
can solve right - I became in machine
learning back when I was an undergrad
actually yeah I went to a machine in
class and it's like ah this is what I
want to do for my life and I've been
pursuing it ever since and here you are
yeah
so we're gonna spend the bulk of our
time today talking about the specific
work you're doing in reinforcement
learning but John before we get into it
give us a little context as a level set
from your perspective what's unique
about reinforcement learning within the
machine learning universe and why is it
an important part of MSRs research
portfolio so most of the machine
learning that's actually deployed is
over the supervised learning variety and
supervised learning is fundamentally
about taking expertise from people and
making that into some sort of learned
function that you can then use to do
some task reinforcement learning is
different because it's about taking
information from the world and learning
a policy for interacting with the world
so that you perform better in one way or
another so that different source of
information can be incredibly powerful
because you could imagine a future where
every time you type on the keyboard the
keyboard learns to understand you better
or every time you interact with some
website it understands better what your
preferences are so the world starts
working better and better and
interacting with people and so
reinforcement learning as an method
within the machine learning world is
different from other methods because you
deploy it in less known circumstances or
how would you define that so it's
different in many ways but the key
difference is the information source the
consequence of that is that
reinforcement can be surprising it can
actually surprise you they can find
solutions you might have not thought of
two problems that you posed to it
has--it's one of the key things another
thing is it requires substantially more
skill to apply than supervised learning
supervised learning is pretty
straightforward as far as the statistics
go while reinforcement learning there's
some little traps out there and you want
to think carefully about what you're
doing let me go into a little more
detail Steve let's suppose you need to
make a sequence of ten steps and you
want to maximize the reward that you're
getting those ten steps right so it
might be the case that going left gives
you a small reward immediately and then
you get no more rewards while if you go
right you get no reward and then you go
left and then
and then right and then left and then
right so on 10 times do it just the
right way you get a big reward and so
many reinforcements aghanim's was just
learned to go left because that gave the
small reward immediately and that gap is
not like a little gap it's like you may
require exponentially many more samples
to learn unless you actually gather the
information in an intelligible conscious
way yeah I'm greening and no one can see
it because I'm thinking that's how
people operate generally you know yeah I
mean the way I explain reinforcement
learning is the way you teach puppy how
to do a trick and the puppy may surprise
you and do something else but the reward
that John speaks off is the treat that
you give the puppy when the puppy does
what you are trying to teach it to do
and sometimes they just surprise you and
do something different and actually
reinforcement learning has a very great
affinity to of love iane psychology
well back to your example John you're
saying if you turn left to get the
reward immediately get a small reward a
small reward so the agent would have to
go through many many steps of this to
figure out don't go left because you'll
get more later you get more later if you
go right and you take the right actions
after you go right now I imagine
explaining this to a customer and we
will get there and I'll have you explain
it
Rapha let's talk for a second about the
personalization service which is an
instantiation of what you call
real-world reinforcement learning yeah
that's right
so you characterized it as a general
framework for reinforcement learning
algorithms that are suitable for real
world applications
unpack that a bit give us a short primer
on real-world reinforcement learning and
why it's an important direction for
reinforcement learning in general yeah
I'll give you my version and I'm sure
John will chime in but you know many of
the reinforcement learning that people
hear about are almost always done in a
simulated environment where you can be
creative as to what you simulate and you
can generate you know gazillions of
samples to make your agents work
our type of ring for John's types
reinforcement learning is something that
we deploy online and what drives us John
and I is to create or use this
methodology to solve real-world problems
and our goal is really to advance the
science in order to help enterprises
maximize their business objective
through the usage of real-world
reinforcement learning so when I say
real-world these are models that we
deploy in production with real users
getting real feedback and they learn on
the job
well John talk a little bit about what
Rafah has alluded to there's an online
real world element to it but prior to
this reinforcement learning has had some
big investments in the gaming space tell
us the difference and what happens when
you move from a very closed environment
to a very open environment from a
technical perspective yeah so I guess
the first thing to understand is why
you'd want to do this because if
reinforcement learning in simulators
works great then why do you need to do
something else and I guess the answer is
there many things you just can't
simulate hmm so an example that I
haven't given talks is would it be
interested in a news article about
Ukraine the answer is yes because my
wife is from Ukraine but you would never
know this your simulator would never
know this to be no way for the policy to
actually learn that if you're learning
in a simulator right so there are many
problems where there are no good
simulators and in those simulators you
don't have a choice so given that you
don't have a choice you need to embrace
the difficulties of the problem so what
are the difficulties of the real-world
reinforcement learning problems well you
don't have a zillion zuv examples which
are typically required for many of the
existing deep reinforcement learning
algorithms you need to be careful about
how you use your samples you need to use
them to maximum and utmost efficiency
and trying to do the learning another
element that happens is often when
people have simulators those simulators
are kind of effectively stationary they
stay the same throughout the process of
training
but in real-world problems many of them
we encounter we run into all kinds of
non-stationarity
there's exhaustive ents the album's need
to be very robust so the combination of
using samples are efficiently in great
robustness in these algorithms are kind
of key offsetting elements from what you
might see in other places which is
challenging
alphago or ms pac-man or the other games
that have been sort of flags waved about
our progress and reinforcement learning
I think those are fun applications I
really enjoy reading about them and
learning about them I think it's a great
demonstration of where the field has
gotten but I feel like this is issue of
AI winter right so there was once a time
when any I crashed when that may happen
again because AEI is now a buzzword but
I think it's important that we actually
do things that have some real value in
the world which actually affect people's
lives because that's what creates a
lasting wave of innovation and puts a
civilization into a new place right so
that's what I'm really seeking what
season are we in now I've heard there
has been more than one AI winter and
summer so it's AI spring where do you
see us in terms of that progress I think
it's fair to say that there's a lot of
froth in terms of people claiming things
that are not going to come to pass at
the same time there is real value being
created suddenly we can do things and
things to work better through some of
these techniques and so there's kind of
this mishmash of over-promised things
that are gonna fail and there are things
that are not over promised and they will
succeed and so if there's enough of
those that succeed then maybe don't have
a winter maybe it just becomes a long
summer like San Diego all the time I
think to comment on John's point here I
think reinforcement learning is a
nascent technique and participative ice
learning and what's important is to do
the crawl walk run rate so yeah it's
sexy now and pee
are talking about it but we need to rein
it in from a business perspective as to
you know what are the classes of
problems that we can satisfy the
business leader with and satisfy them
effectively rate and I think from a
reinforcement learning John correct me
we are very much at the cross phase and
solving generic business problems and we
have solved some generic business
problems but we don't have widely
deployed or deployable platforms for
reusing those solutions over and over
again and it's so easy to imagine many
more applications and people have even
tried so we're nowhere near mature phase
in terms of even simple kinds of
reinforcement learning we are ramping up
in our ability to solve real-world
reinforcement learning problems
headington there's a huge ramp sail to
heaven heading towards your goal of
solving machine learning yes but I mean
to be fair though we can actually
satisfy some classes of problems really
well with nascent technology so yes we
are nascent and the world is out there
for us to conquer but I think we do have
techniques that can solve a whole swath
of problems and it's up to us to harvest
that
[Music]
well let's continue the thread a little
bit on the research areas of
reinforcement learning and there's
several that seem to be gaining traction
let's go sort of high-level and talk
about this one area that you're saying
is basically creating a new foundation
for reinforcement learning what's wrong
with the current foundation well how do
we meet the new foundation for and what
are you doing
the current foundation of reinforcement
learning is called a Markov decision
process the idea and amarka decision
processes you have states and actions
and given a state you take an action
then you have some distribution over the
next state so that's kind of what the
foundation is if everybody describes
your solutions and the core issue with
this is that there are no good solutions
when you have a large number of states
all solutions kind of scale with the
number of states and so if you have a
small number of possible observations
about the world then you can employ
these theoretically motivated
reinforcement learning algorithms which
are provably efficient and they will
work well but in the real world you have
a megapixel camera which has 2 to the 1
million or 16 to the 1 million possible
inputs and so you never in kind of the
same thing twice and so you just can't
even apply these algorithms it doesn't
even make sense it's ridiculous
so when I was a young graduate student
that was of course learning about Markov
decision processes and trying to figure
out how to solve reinforcement learning
better with them and then at some point
after we had a breakthrough I realized
that the breakthrough was meaningless
because it was all about these
marketization processes and no matter
what it just never was going to get to
the point where you could actually do
something useful
so around 2007 I decided to start
working on contextual bandits this is an
expansion of what reinforcement learning
means in one sense but a restriction in
another sense so instead of caring about
the reward of a long sequence of actions
we're gonna care about the reward of the
next action alright so that's a big
simplification on the other hand instead
of caring about the state we're gonna
care about an observation
and we're going to demand that our
algorithms don't depend upon the number
of possible observations just like they
do in supervised learning so we studied
this for several years we discovered how
to create statistically efficient
algorithms for these kinds of problems
so that's kind of the foundation of the
systems that we've been working on and
then more recently after cracking these
connection abandoned problems we wanted
to address a larger piece of
reinforcement learning so now we're
thinking about contextual decision
processes where you have a sequence of
rounds and on each round you see some
observation you choose some action and
then again and again and again and then
at the end of an episode maybe ten steps
maybe 100 you get a reward right so
there's some long delayed reward
dependent upon all the actions you've
taken and all the observations you've
made and now it turns out that when
these observations are generated by some
small underlying state space which you
do not know in advance in then which has
never told to you you can still learn
you can still do reinforcement learning
you can efficiently discover what a good
policy is globally so the new foundation
of reinforcement learning is about
creating a foundation for reinforcement
algorithms that can cope with a
megapixel camera as an observation
rather than having like ten discrete or
100 discrete states and you're getting
some good traction with this approach
yeah I mean contextual bandits are
deployed in the real world and being
used in many places at this point
there's every reason to believe that if
we can crack contextual decision
processes which is our current agenda
that will be of great use as well Rapha
at its core reinforcement learning
systems are designed to be self
improving systems and kind of learn from
the real world like humans do yes or
puppies and the real world is uncertain
and risky yes so how do you from your
perspective or from your angle build
trust with the customers that you
interact with both third party and first
party customers who are giving you
access to their own real-life traffic
online yeah this is an important topic
when we start looking at how we do
incubations in our team and we have a
specific challenge as you are saying
because if we were a supervised learning
model we would go to a customer and say
hey you know give me a data set I'll run
my algorithm if it improves you deploy
it we deployed in an a/b test and if we
are good you're good to go
our system is deployed in production so
here we are with customers and talking
to them about advanced machine learning
techniques from research and we want to
deploy them in their online production
system so as you can imagine it becomes
an interesting conversation so the way
we approach this actually is by taking
ideas from product teams so when we went
and did our incubations
we did it with a hardened prototype
meaning this is a prototype that's not
your typical stitched up Python code
that you know is hacky we took a fair
amount of time to harden it to the
degree that if you run it and production
is not going to crash your customers
online production system so that's
number one and then when we approach
customers our system learns from the
real world and you do need a certain
amount of traffic because our models are
like newborn puppies they don't know any
tricks so you need to give them
information in order to learn but what
we typically do is we have a
conversation with our customer and say
hey you know yes this is research but it
is hard and prototype that's number one
and two we use previous incubations as
reference to newer ones we borrow ideas
from how products go sell their
prototypes right and then we as a
methodology say to customers when they
have large volumes of traffic to give us
a portion of their traffic which is good
enough for us to learn and prove the ROI
but small enough for them to de-risk and
that methodology has
worked very well for us d risk is such a
good word let's go a little further on
that thread talk a little bit about the
cold start versus the warm start when
you're deploying so that's another
interesting conversation with our
customers especially those that are used
to supervised learning where you train
your model rate with a lot of data and
you deploy it and it's already learned
something our models and our
personalization service start really
cold but the way John and the teams
created those algorithms allows us to
learn very fast and the more traffic you
give it the faster it learn so I'll give
you an example we deployed a pilot with
Xbox top of home where we were
personalizing two of the three slots or
four slots that they have on the top of
home and Xbox gets in millions of events
per day so with only six million events
per day which is a fraction of Xbox
traffic in about a couple of hours we
went from cold to very warm so again
from addy risking with these
conversations with our customers first
or third parties we tend to say yes it's
cold start but these algorithms learned
super fast and there's a certain amount
of traffic flow that enables that
efficient learning so we haven't had
major problems we start by making our
customers understand how the system
works and we go from there
are there instances where you're coming
into a warm start where there's some
existing data or infrastructure yeah so
that definitely happens it's typically
more trouble than it's worth to actually
use pre-existing data because when
you're training in a contextual bandit
you really need to capture four things
the features the action the reward for
the action and then the probability of
taking the action and almost always the
probability is not recorded in any kind
of reliable way if it was even
randomized previously so given you lack
one of those things you can there ways
to try to repair that
they kind of work with the kind of pain
and not the kind of thing that you can
do in an automatic fashion so typically
we want to start with recording our own
data so we can be sure that it is in
fact good data now with that said there
are many techniques for taking into
account pre-existing models right so we
actually have a paper now an archive
talking about how to combine an existing
supervised data source where the context
of MANET data source another approach
which is commonly very helpful is people
may have existing supervised system
which may be very complex and they may
have built up a lot of features around
that which may not even be appropriate
often there's a process around any kind
of real system where the learning
algorithm the features are kind of Co
evolving and so moving away from either
them causes a degradation in performance
so in that kind what you'd want to do is
you want to tap the existing supervised
models to extract features which are
very powerful and then given those very
powerful features you can very quickly
get to a good solution and then so the
exact mechanism of that extraction it's
gonna depend upon the representation
that you're using with a neural network
you kind of rip off the top layer and
use that with a decision tree or a bush
decision tree or decision forest you can
use the leaf membership as a feature
that you can then feed in for a very
fast warm up of a conditional Bennett
learner John talked about offline
experimentations what's going on there
yeah so this is one of the really cool
things that's possible when you're doing
shallow kinds of reinforcement
reinforcement learning with me one step
or maybe two steps so if you record that
quad of features action reward and the
probability then it becomes possible to
evaluate any policy that chooses amongst
the set of available actions okay so
what that means is that if you record
this data and then later you discover
that may be a different learning rate
was helpful or maybe you should be
taking this feature in that feature and
combining them to make a new feature you
can test to see exactly how that would
have performed if you had deploy
policy at the time you're collecting
data so this is amazing because this
means that you no longer need to use an
a/b test for the purpose of optimization
you still have reasons to use it for
purpose of safety but for optimization
you can do that offline in a minute
rather than doing it online for two
weeks waiting to get the data necessary
to actually learn yeah just to pick up
on why is this a gold nugget they are
assigned to spend fair amount of time
today designing models a priori and
testing them in a B test only to learn
two weeks after that they failed and
they go back to Ground Zero so here are
you're running hundreds if not thousands
of a B tests on this pod and when we
talk about this to data scientist and
enterprises their eyes light up I mean
that is one of the key features of our
system that just brightens the day for
many data scientists it's a real pain
for them to design models run them in a
B it's very costly as well so talk about
productivity gains its immense when you
can run a hundred to 200 a B tests in a
minute versus running one a B test for
two weeks
Rapha you work as a program manager
within a research organization yes and
it's your job to bring science to the
people yes talk about your process a
little more in detail of research
incubate transfer in the context of how
you develop our L prototypes and
engineer them and how you test them and
specifically maybe you could explain a
couple of examples of this process of
deployments that are out there already
how are you living up to the code we
have a decent size engineering team that
supports our RL efforts and MSR and our
job is twofold
one is to from a program management
perspective it's to really drive what it
means to go from an algorithm to a
prototype and then validate whether that
prototype has any market potential I
take it upon me as a program manager
when researchers are
creating these wonderful academic papers
with great algorithm and some of them
may have huge market potential so this
market analysis happens actually an MSR
and we ask ourselves great algorithm
what are the classes of problems we can
solve for it and what people like relate
to these problems such that we could
actually go and incubate them and the
incubation is a validation of this
market hypothesis so that's what we do
in our incue bation we are actually
trying to see whether this is something
that we could potentially tech transfer
to the product team and we've done this
with contextual bandits in the context
of personalization scenarios so
contextual bandits is a technique rate
and so we ask ourselves okay with this
technique what classes of problems can
we solve very efficiently and
personalization was one of them and we
went and incubated at first with msn
actually John and the team incubated it
with msn first and they got at 26
percent lift multi-million dollar
revenue potential so from a market
potential it really made sense so we
went and said okay one customer is not
statistically significant so we need to
do more and we spent a fair amount of
time actually validating this idea and
validating the different types of
personalization so MSN was a news
article personalization recently we did
a page layout personalization was
surfaced calm Japan where they had four
boxes on surface that come to pen and
they were wondering how to present these
boxes based on the user that was
visiting that page and guess what we
gave them
2,500 events I was a short-run pilot
that we did with them we gave them an 80
percent lift 80 they were flabbergasted
they couldn't believe and this was run
on an a/b test so they had their page
layout that their designers had
specified for them for all users running
as the
control and they had our personalization
engine running with our contextual
bandit algorithm and they ran it and for
us you know 2500 samples is not really a
lot but even with that we gave them an
80 percent lift over their control so
these are the kinds of incubation that
when we go to our sister product team in
Redmond and tell the story they get
super excited that this could be a
classes of application that could work
for the masses
[Music]
John there's a lot of talk today about
diversity and that often means having
different people on the team but there's
other aspects especially in
reinforcement learning that include
diversity of perspective and approach
how do you address this in the work
you're doing and how do you practically
manage it one thing to understand is
that research is an extreme sport in
many ways do you try to do something
else nobody has ever done before and so
you need an environment that supports
you in doing this in many ways it's hard
for a single researcher to have all the
abilities that are needed to succeed
when you're learning to do research
you're typically learning a very narrow
thing and over time maybe that gets a
little bit broader but it's still gonna
be the case that you just know a very
narrow perspective on how to solve a
problem so one things that we actually
do is on a weekly basis we have an open
problems discussion where a group of
researchers gets together and one of
them talks about the problem they're
interested in and then other people
couldn't I'm in and say oh maybe she
look at this way or think about that way
that helps I think sharpen the problems
and then in the process of solving
problems amazing things come up in
discussion but they can only come up if
you can listen to each other and I guess
the people that I prefer to work with
are the ones who listen carefully
there's a process of bouncing ideas off
each other
discovering the flaws in them figuring
out how to get around the flaws this
process can go on it's indefinite but
sometimes it lands and we're gonna lands
at that moment when you discover
something that's really something Rafa
do you anything to add to that so when I
think about diversity in our lab I think
that to complement what John's saying I
like to always also think about the
diversity of disciplines so in our lab
we're not a big lab but we have
researchers we have engineers we have
designers and we have program manager
and I think these skill set are diverse
and they complement
each other so well and I think that adds
to the richness of what we have in our
lab in the context of the work you do
it's applications and implications in
the real world is there anything that
keeps you up at night any concerns
you're working to mitigate even as you
work to innovate I think the answer is
yes anybody who understands the
potential of machine learning AI
whatever you want to call it understands
that there are negative ways to use it
all right
it is a tool and we need to try to use
the tool responsibly and we need to
mitigate the downsides where we can see
them advance so I do wonder about this
recently we had a paper on fairer
machine learning and we showed that any
supervised learning algorithm can in the
black box fashion be turned into a fair
supervised learning algorithm we
demonstrated this both theoretically and
experimentally so that's a promising
paper that addresses a narrow piece of
ethics around a I guess I would say yeah
as we see more opportunities along these
lines we will solve them yeah also use
these techniques for the social good
right I mean as we are trying to use
them to monetize also we should use them
for the social good how did each of you
end up at Microsoft Research in New York
City this is actually quite a story so I
used to be at Yahoo research one day
right about now seven years ago the head
of Yahoo research quit so we decided to
essentially sell the New York Lab so we
created a portfolio of everybody in the
New York lab and fifteen researchers
there we sent it around to various
companies Microsoft ended up getting 13
out of 15 people and that was the
beginning of Microsoft Research New York
Rafa how did you come to Microsoft
Research in New York City he told me I
was gonna revolutionize the world that's
why I came over from IBM so I actually
had a wonderful job at IBM applying
Watson technologies for children's
education
and one day a Microsoft recruiter called
me and they said John Lankford renowned
RL researcher is looking for a program
manager you should interview with him
and I'm like okay so interviewed at
Microsoft Research New York spoke to
many people and at the time I you know I
was comfortable in my job and I had
other opportunities but in his selling
pitch to me John Lankford calls me one
day at home and he says you should
choose to come and work for Microsoft
Research because we're gonna
revolutionize the world and I think it
sunk in that we can be at the cusp of
something really big and that got me
really excited to join and that's how I
ended up at Microsoft Research as we
close I'd like each of you to address a
big statement that you've made John you
started out our interview with I want to
solve machine learning Rapha you have
said that your ultimate goal is
real-world reinforcement learning for
everyone what does the world look like
if each of you is wildly successful yeah
so there's a lot of things that are easy
to imagine being a part of the future
world that just aren't around now you
should imagine that every computer
interface learns to adapt to you rather
than you needing to adapt to the user
interface you could imagine lots of
companies just working better you could
imagine a digital avatar that over time
learns to help you book the flights that
you want a book or things like that
right often there's a lot of mundane
tasks that people do over and over again
and if you have a system that can record
and learn from all the interactions that
you make with computers or with the
internet it can happen on your behalf
that could really ease the lives of
people in many different ways
lots of things where there's an
immediate sense of oh that was the right
outcome or oh that was the wrong outcome
can be addressed with just the
technology that we have already and then
there's technologies beyond that like
the contextual decision for us
that are talking about that may open up
even more possibilities in the future
Rafa to me what a bright future would
look like is when we can cast a lot of
issues that we see today problems
enterprises and at the personal level as
a reinforcement learning problem that we
can actually solve and more importantly
for me you know as we work in technology
and we develop all these techniques the
question is are we making the world a
better world right and can we actually
solve some hard problems like famine and
diseases with reinforcement learning and
maybe not now but can it be the bright
feature that we look out for I hope so I
do too John Langford Rafa hosen thank
you for joining us today thank you thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
to learn more about dr. John Langford
and Rafa hozen and the quest to bring
reinforcement learning to the real world
visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]